okay everyone new footage of the
upcoming black panther film gave us an
extended look at the foot chase scene
set in south korea now the scene gives
us some new details showing the amazing
technology of Wakanda and some
interesting features a black panther
suit so I thought let's zoom and enhance
on this footage shall we yeah the scene
begins with Sheree providing T'Challa
support by activating the car remotely
with a scanner on the hood mapping the
cars structure as a holo display in our
lab back in Wakanda if you look closely
Shirdi has the car seat the steering
wheel pedal all laid out the rest of the
cards kind of projects around here yes
it's not a real so I just exactly skim
through the scene because I'm trying to
trying to be careful I want to ëismí
surprises my service leader it's
possible that's not about the car looks
like on the inside cuz I was like oh
well Khan has got their own cars and
they look like this on the inside only
the steering wheel everything else is
mapped projection around her hologram
yeah that'd be cool that would impact
okay now I'm getting a you know Sam mode
I think what's what's interesting if you
look closely in addition to the car as
Sheree drives you could see the city
street to South Korea the South Korean
city street passing by her outside also
as a hologram kind of like the x-men
danger room type thing how the hell is
this possible right if you think about
this how would you be able to also show
a realistic display real quick I think
it's important for people that haven't
watched this scene to clarify exactly
how this is playing out she is in her
lab she is not on the road right now but
it looks very much like she's on the
road so here's we did a Photoshop
mock-up of like here's what you would
expect to see she's in a hologram and
the lab is behind her but instead
waitwait went out is that suddenly she's
transported you know in in a visual way
at least as if she's on that road in the
city actually you see earlier in the
clip there's a hood scanner that's on
the hood of the car that is Mac you know
collecting all this data and mapping it
but I think what it's saying is that
this technology is so elaborate and maps
the surrounding surfaces that this place
is within as well maybe kind of like
taking a 3d photograph of the street
likes Google a Google Street View I
think it's a good analogy for it like
and then it digitally reinsert this
hologram car from Cherise point of view
in that wreck
the 3d environment that's crazy
Ammar seems just as easy huh yeah but
you can't you know make it that cool
cute little magnet you can't have your
gel car I think we're gonna see this is
just the tip of the iceberg of the
elaborate technology that what Conda has
maybe not everyone this is Sheree she is
like the Tony Stark of this of this
world and she has special access to
things and she's like super brilliant
but I'm super excited to see what other
kinds of hologram projection we see in
this movie we all saw her kill someone
okay well next we also see how black
panther's vibranium suit is stored
inside of his necklace it extends
outward from that necklace as his body
similar to Tony Stark's repulsor
crawling out from his wristwatch and
Civil War some interesting parallels and
it would be fun to see these characters
work together in the future
but later as enemies shoot it to Chara
and the bullets ricochet off his
vibranium sharee explains how each
impact is causing kinetic energy to
build up creating this purple glow
inside of a suit which she releases in
the form of this awesome shockwave that
is so cool yeah super powerful feature
for a suit to be able to convert a
defensive advantage his bulletproof
armor into an offensive weapon I always
thought that was one of the coolest
superpowers there's you know speedball
from speedball is the famous he does bad
stuff he does bad stuff your villain
he's a not by accident yeah mainly by
accident but he's something yeah he
takes the kinetic energy can like any
can Expo it out and I always thought
that was so cool it's like so no matter
what if you get hurt and get punched
it's just like this is just gonna come
back and hurt you even if you try to
shoot me I can just absorb all that
energy and throw it right back at you
and then applying it to Black Panther
that's really cool to make him a little
bit more unique instead of just claws
and punching you know he needs a little
bit more than yeah this must be part of
his new suit right cuz we didn't we
would have seen this used in Civil War
there's so many opportunities for him to
use and he didn't so I think you know in
the trailer footage it looks like Sheree
is showing them a new suit it looks like
that's kind of the big selling point I
know Eric how much kinetic energy is
contained in
fired bullet mmm it's probably measured
in joules I don't know 30 joules how
someone correct hit on that so I let us
know actually that's a trick question if
it's stored its potential energy right
yeah
moving well it's moving yeah when the
impact but once it gets stored inside
this it was interesting she said kinetic
energy I'm sure there might have been
some physicists or like if it's stored
at the at that point the bullets were
done firing but when it's used again it
gets transferred in the moment it
touches his suit yeah it is at that
moment kinetic energy yeah yeah yeah
yeah we're gonna get so corrected like
it's like a berry Neil deGrasse Tyson is
just dropping this mic you want to know
I legitimately do want to know like how
much power is he hitting these people
back with if it's let's say 10 bullets
yeah and then comparing that to like a
grenade that goes on that's a foursome
yeah yeah I know awesome
well let us know what you guys think
about these features physicists yell at
us I let you down and I wanna know from
you guys do you think like panthers sued
has the potential to be even more
powerful than what we've seen from Iron
Man Iron Man might want to you know copy
some of the notes from her from her
playbook there but comment down below
and tweet us with your thoughts and as a
reminder subscribe to new rock stars for
all of our deep dives in the black
panther and everything you love thanks
guys